I just sometimes want to be
alone where I'm not somebody's wife not
somebody's
mother or I'm not defined by
tragedy don't you ever miss it
home I like our life
here the help the driver makes
everything
easier as she's family you know you
always say that right you're her
employer not her
[Music]
friend know Hong Kong was supposed to be
a fresh start for me a fresh start
really at
24 I think my marriage is over has David
been home no ma'am what am I still doing
here do you ever imagine yourself living
a completely different
[Music]
life go grab it you
know you're just watching them every
second even when your eyes are closed
and I have no idea how it
happened no one should ever have to go
through what you're going
through
I think we need to think about getting
out of here cuz we're drowning and you
don't see it the minute our feet leave
Hong Kong soil we are abandoning our
son why is she
[Music]
here not a moment goes by where I'm not
think thinking about what I've
done people like me do they ever move
on you're not betraying anyone by trying
to live a better
life we all need to keep
[Music]
living even
you
yeah